jusqu'à récemment, je travaillais dans l'
industrie aéronautique, c'est l'un des
endroits les plus intéressants et les plus étonnants pour
travailler pour un ingénieur, vous pouvez trouver en
un seul endroit des personnes d'
horizons différents des ingénieurs des concepteurs des experts
de tous les domaines techniques et vous trouvez
les plus talentueux avec eux  réunis
autour d'un seul produit qui fait que les
gens s'envolent tous ces gens sont
engagés dans leur travail d'une manière que vous
pourriez même considérer comme
inappropriée ils aiment ce qu'ils font
ils mettent tellement de patience à construire des avions
mais quand vous venez avec un nouveau  ID
défiant un peu la façon dont nous fabriquons les
avions même une petite évolution vous obtenez
des retours instantanés les gens rejettent les tities
très rapidement beaucoup de gens vous disent eh bien
ça ne va pas être possible ça
va être trop dur si ça n'en vaut pas la peine comment
ça peut être sérieux  comment se fait-il que
les gens qui construisent des avions que les
gens font voler les gens hésitent également à
changer un seul morceau de l'avion comment cela peut-
il être t  quel que soit leur âge,
peu importe qu'ils soient concepteurs
ingénieurs pilotes avocats pourquoi enfreindre les
règles est-il si difficile pour eux tout le
temps le statu quo ne
rien changer semble être l'option préférée
bien sûr nous pourrions dire que nous parlons
d'avions  changer quelque chose dans l'
avion n'est pas facile vous prenez le risque
que des gens volent dans les airs mais bon
prenons quelque
chose de plus simple quelque chose de plus simple d'accord sommes-nous d'accord que
c'est plus simple que l'avion plus d'
excuses maintenant je vais juste vous poser deux
questions simples  le premier ceux d'entre
vous qui ont un parapluie qui a l'air
complètement différent de celui-ci pouvez-
vous lever la main whoa cinq ou six
excellente deuxième question celui d'entre vous qui
estime que le parapluie est parfaitement
conçu je suis pratique facile à utiliser pour
vous protéger  correctement facile à ranger
vous aimez les utiliser quand il y a du vent je
veux dire pouvez-vous lever la main si vous êtes
parfaitement satisfait des parapluies d'accord
un deux trois quatre d'accord cinq  sur plus
de 100 conclusions, ce que je veux que vous
ressentiez, c'est que même un objet simple comme
un parapluie, même si personne n'est content
de ce qu'il nous apporte, aucune amélioration majeure ne
semble se produire, le parapluie est
stable, il n'évolue pas, il ne
change pas.  un regard sur un autre
exemple d'une autre industrie c'est une
courte vidéo nous remontons dans le temps il y a
quelques années dans l'industrie informatique
rappelez-vous comment les gens ont réagi quand Apple a
décidé de supprimer un lecteur de CD et
SN il nous connecte depuis l'ordinateur portable
c'est  une annonce qui était sur Internet faite
par un concurrent très sérieux provenait d'
hommes là-dessus montre que la plupart de l'
industrie informatique a rejeté ce qui n'est pas courant ce que
nous appelons pas d'ultrabooks qui est un
objet remarquable aujourd'hui, mais il y a quelques années, c'était
quelque chose qui était un changement radical
sans que tout le monde ait presque tous été
rejetés à ce moment-là,
Apple a enfreint une règle, ils ont décidé de
changer la façon dont nous utilisons pour définir et
concevoir des ordinateurs portables pourquoi est-ce si
difficile pourquoi est-ce  il est si difficile pour nous tous
de changer quelque chose même quand c'est
un tel détail pourquoi tout le monde, y compris les
plus talentueux, était de brillants
ingénieurs concepteurs industriels si rapidement fixés sur
ce qu'un objet peut ou devrait être nous
pourrions dire que son phénomène humain naturel
cet humain  les êtres sont
réticents à changer mais pouvons-nous
sérieusement accepter cela au moins je ne
crois pas que nous devrions changer autour de nous
se produisent si vite aujourd'hui que si nous
gardons ce sentiment négatif de
changer notre vie sera de plus en plus
difficile chaque jour les choses sont  bouger autour de
nous chaque enfant aujourd'hui devrait être
éduqué à apprécier le changement plutôt que d'en
avoir peur le changement devrait être un
terrain de jeu pour les enfants alors que pouvons-nous
faire avec certitude la nature joue contre nous notre
cerveau comme tendance naturelle à créer des
boîtes pour classer les choses à
nous simplifier la vie
exactement comme le fait le biologiste lorsqu'il
trouve de nouvelles espèces de nouvelles espèces notre
cerveau essaie de mettre des cases pour créer des cases
pour créer des catégories  à toutes les choses
dans notre esprit et ces catégories, ces
boîtes sont assez rigides, elles sont
assez difficiles à changer une fois que nous avons défini
qu'est-ce qu'une voiture était un parapluie qu'est-ce qu'un
avion et ce qu'il devrait être, mais après
cela, nous pourrions faire quelque chose à faire
changer moins moins violent pour nous on pourrait
essayer d'éviter de renforcer notre cerveau
tendance naturelle à créer des boites si
on regarde ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui depuis nos
tout débuts on nous apprend à
bien définir les choses on crée même des
livres comme ça je veux dire  des milliers de
pages remplies de définitions de ce que sont
les objets ces livres n'évoluent pas
si vite ce sont des
définitions statiques de tout le monde qui
nous entoure nous les appelons des dictionnaires ils sont
censés nous donner le sens exact d'
un mot laissez-moi vous expliquer si nous prenons  la
définition du parapluie le parapluie
est censé être un dispositif constitué d'
un auvent circulaire de buts sur
des cadres métalliques pliants bordés par
votre tige centrale servant de protection contre les
rai  n maintenant avec cette définition à l'esprit si
vous demandez à quelqu'un d'améliorer le parapluie
que pouvez-vous faire sérieusement s'il s'agit d'un
parapluie que pouvez-vous faire déplacer un peu de
métal changer la couleur améliorer le
mécanisme de pliage c'est vraiment le niveau de
refonte que nous attendons  pour avoir de meilleurs
parapluies sentez-vous la fixation du
pouvoir de la définition que nous créons
ces définitions nous donne une
vision claire de ce qu'est l'objet mais ensuite pour
que l'objet reste le même
si nous prenons un peu de recul, nous pourrions nous
demander qui a écrit  cette définition d'où
vient-elle en fait la définition
est une conséquence directe de la conception de l'
objet chaque fois qu'un nouvel objet apparaît être
le produit le parapluie ou le service de
livraison de sushi par exemple il faut du temps
à l'industrie pour s'entendre sur
ce qui a du sens  ce qui fonctionne correctement mais
après quelques variations initiales quelques
que onda différentes des rails de vos
objets insolites l'identité de l'
objet stabilise le nom et la
définition les trouver  r chemin dans le
dictionnaire et cela devient
ce qu'est le parapluie jetons un coup d'œil
aux objets plus jeunes SmartWatch par
exemple la définition est un
appareil mobile avec un écran tactile
conçu pour être porté au poignet même
si cela sonne plutôt bien pour celui
que nous avons ici si nous jetons un coup d'œil à
celui-ci c'est la dernière avec des choses
activité il compte vos pas vous
parle de votre activité quotidienne vous réveille
en silence le matin essentiellement vous
sentez que c'est assez intelligent pour que
les bêtes soient appelées  quelque chose d'intelligent
ça ressemble à une montre mais si on prend la
définition ce n'est pas dans le champ d'application de la
DTV de la définition n'a pas d'écran tactile
affichage classique analogique comme n'importe quelle
montre suisse sentez-vous à quel point nos
définitions dans nos dictionnaires sont pauvres pour
parler de la  évolution des objets
qui nous entourent dans quelle mesure ils
réparent des choses que nous ne voulons pas vraiment
tout ce que nous n'avons pas eu tendance à réparer
si nous jetons un coup d'œil à notre éducation
l'équilibre entre le temps
passé à apprendre une définition stable des
choses et le temps passé à nous
apprendre à redéfinir les choses ou à créer des
définitions est assez clair c'est environ
quatre-vingt-dix-huit pour cent de notre temps passé
à apprendre plutôt qu'à remettre en question les
choses quand était la dernière fois que  on vous
a demandé
de créer une définition pour les
scientifiques parmi vous peut-être le jour où nous
introduisons les nombres complexes peut-être que ce jour-là
nous vous avons dit que nous devions redéfinir ce qu'est le
nombre nous avons dû admettre que de nouveaux
nombres pourraient avoir un carré négatif ce
jour-là en une seconde  quelqu'un a changé
tout ce que vous apprenez pendant 18 ans
avant de vous rappeler comment il se sentait ce
genre de mélange excitant de colère peur
liberté pouvoir c'est un changement cela
change la définition à partir de maintenant comment pouvons-
nous espérer que le monde
s'améliorera considérablement si nous continuons à former les
gens pour  gérer l'amélioration
marginale des changements marginaux sur l'objet
qui nous entoure les gens sont formés pour
concevoir des choses qui sont parfaites  y en
respectant les contours du siècle toutes les
définitions pouvons-nous encore croire que le
changement se produira sans nous nous ne le
croyons pas au moins pour pouvoir
repenser les choses pour aller au-delà de leurs
définitions classiques nous avons besoin d'un nouveau type
d'approche et nous en avons besoin maintenant  nous avons besoin
qu'il soit répandu non seulement pour les ingénieurs mais
seulement pour les concepteurs mais pour nos
politiciens sont des journalistes tout le
monde nous entoure il s'agit de gens d'affaires
il s'agit de tout le monde basé sur les dernières
recherches en sciences du design nous introduisons la
génétique des choses aux filets de choses
introduit offre un nouveau cadre
analyser les définitions des objets et
voir comment ils peuvent évoluer l'idée est très
simple derrière elle l'identité de tout
objet va bien au-delà de la définition classique que
vous trouvez dans le dictionnaire il
résulte d'une conception initiale et d'années
d'évolution à
travers l'utilisation H à travers l'artisanat des personnes
façonner année après année l'objet avec
lequel ils interagissent les choses telles
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui sont le résultat d'un long
processus d'évolution invisible et lente
par exemple chaque génération de manette
représentée ici hérite des gènes de la
génération précédente et il y a de légères
petites rotations dans ce processus nous
jouons tous un rôle en utilisant la génétique des choses nous
pouvons rendre explicites tous les choix oubliés et
invisibles  dans la conception de tout
objet et donc ce que nous pouvons faire est de
discuter de la fixation que nous avons à l'
esprit avec nos définitions classiques et
ensuite forcer la génération de nouvelles
variations de nouvelles mutations des objets
exactement comme les générations révèlent l'ADN de
tout être vivant que nous pouvons  faites de même pour
les artefacts de Human Design une fois que l'ADN est
visible n'importe qui peut explorer la mutation
qui valorise ce qu'il pourrait nous offrir si
nous prenons l'exemple d'une voiture c'est la
définition classique que cette définition
ne mentionne pas et cela ne nous permet
pas de  contester le fait que cette voiture
est conçue pour être conduite par une seule personne
que cette personne possède un permis de conduire
que cette personne est à bord à l'intérieur du
voiture elle se déplace sur des routes faites spécialement
pour les appels pendant des années elle a des portes qui
peuvent être maintenues fermées etc etc la plupart des
approches d'ingénierie classiques ont
le troupeau de la conception de la prochaine
génération de voitures prendre toutes ces
caractéristiques pour acquises nous devons
changer cela  nous devons pouvoir
défier les routes dont nous avons besoin pour
pouvoir changer le fait qu'il y a un conducteur
à bord et nous sommes ici avec vous pour
parler de génétique des choses parce que
nous nous soucions parce que nous croyons que l'
amélioration du monde dans lequel nous vivons
est un  travail quotidien pour chacun
d'entre vous parce que nos enfants
améliorent non seulement l'objet dans
lequel nous vivons, mais aussi la façon dont nous les
éduquons, la façon dont nous leur donnons les moyens de créer le
changement m.  show dit l'homme raisonnable
s'adapte au monde l'
homme déraisonnable persiste à essayer de
s'adapter pour adapter le monde à lui-même
donc tout le progrès dépend de
l'homme déraisonnable on ne pense pas que ce soit une
question de raison on pense que c'est une question de méthodes
et d'éducation donc  combien de temps continuerez-vous à
concevoir des objets sans remettre en question
l'ADN combien de temps penserez-vous que la
route est accordée lorsque vous concevez une voiture nous
tous les concepteurs nous avons tous besoin de changer le
jeu au jour le jour devriez-vous garder un
seul identifiant sur la génétique des choses garder
celui-ci en ligne au lieu de concevoir
à l'intérieur de la définition permettez-vous de
reconcevoir la définition elle-même merci
beaucoup